[Music]
what's
wrong with them what are you talking
about
they're so quiet are they on medication
no they're just smart like you
i've been going to school in a zoo not
sure about these uniforms
kind of frou-frou
sheldon i've been looking over your
transcripts and i must say i'm very
impressed
thank you what's your doctrine
non-commutative algebraic topology
i like her it's gonna be weird around
here without sheldon
don't you mean less weird that's not
nice i wasn't trying for nice
you sure you're not jealous cause your
little brother's moving up in the world
hey i got plans of my own do tell
as soon as i graduate high school i'm
gonna be a professional male model
that is hilarious what i'm good-looking
know that you think you'll graduate high
school
the model thing was funny too
i must tell you in all the years i've
been here i have never seen such glowing
letters of recommendation from a
student's teachers
well that's real nice to hear now listen
to this putting aside his superior
intellect
sheldon is a delight to have in the
class he's fun-loving
easy to get along with and always ready
to help another student
that doesn't sound like me at all sure
it does sweetie dr douglas oh no
please call me flora flora i have to ask
about the living arrangements that's our
main concern
well i think i can reassure you about
that my husband and i have been hosting
a student for the last several years who
recently graduated
and is now in princeton so we have a
guest room available in our home
well i was very generous of you is your
husband working to school also
no he's retired he was an astrophysicist
for
please tell me you don't have a dog no
we're both allergic
i'm tingling
mimo mimo
wow i know i look great
i got you a little going away gift come
on in
this necklace has been in our family for
generations
it belonged to a comanche warrior who
gave it to your
great-great-great-great-grandma
why'd he give it to her well according
to family lore she was uh
a very accommodating young lady and uh
they hit it off
that's a bird feather eagle feather
doesn't matter
i don't like birds birds are filthy okay
fine one featherless
family heirloom for you to take with you
and keep you safe while you're away
you don't actually believe this has
magic powers do you
oh for god's sake just say thank you
thank you
there's a price tag on it
no there's not
[Music]
mm-hmm